sí
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta soy ángela gómez por
paula gimenez y el reportaje de hoy nos
lleva hasta el sur de nigeria 12 años
después de uno de los peores derrames de
petróleo de la historia o bonnie land ya
sigue siendo un cementerio de manglares
y ríos hacia el mar el lugar que antes
fue un santuario natural hoy sigue sin
ser descontaminado a costa de la pobreza
y del sufrimiento de los pescadores
locales
la compañía anglo neerlandesas él ha
evadido su responsabilidad y nigeria le
falló a sus ciudadanos
hoy aún flotan en el agua las capas de
petróleo no hay trabajo ni comida y
sigue la lucha por las indemnizaciones
precisamente nuestros periodistas
conversaron con las familias que aún
están rotas por la pérdida de sus
hogares y también por el fallecimiento
de sus familiares ejecutados que se
abocaron por el activismo para exigir
justicia y reparación veamos la historia
un paisaje aún muy deteriorado 12 años
después de uno de los peores derrames de
petróleo de la historia en el sur de
nigeria
[Música]
ogoniland ya era un santuario ecológico
antes de las grandes fugas en las
instalaciones de la empresa anglo
neerlandesas él
en todo los habitantes han vivido de la
pesca durante generaciones
al igual que la familia de célestin y
viola
este pescador de más de 60 años siempre
ha vivido junto al agua
y no hay manera de que pueda pescar aquí
dijo
y quedó así en casa sin hacer nada por
eso me volví pobre
es el padre de familia tengo esposa e
hijos que dependen de mí
y mi fuente de ingresos fue destruida
tras las catástrofes de 2008 y 2009 en
ogoniland ya los manglares el río y los
arroyos se convirtieron en cementerios
al aire libre
para los barcos de los pescadores
y aquí nadie cuenta con los medios para
ir a mar abierto lejos de las zonas
contaminadas un pescador ya no puede
construir una casa los pescadores tienen
muchas dificultades para alimentarse
sales a pescar y vuelves con las manos
vacías si alquilas un barco significa
que cuando vuelvas tienes que pedir
dinero prestado para pagar el barco ese
día esa es la situación para nosotros
ahora
las capas de petróleo flotan en la
superficie del agua a pesar de esto
algunos pescadores se aventuran a lanzar
sus redes en el agua contaminada
y todos los peces que se ven dependen de
este cielo
se alimentan de él una cosa curiosa es
que si uno mira bien
cualquier vez que viene al mar el que
entra aquí ahora
uno ve que tienen los ojos hinchados y
una cola minúscula ja fpa
según el programa de las naciones unidas
para el medio ambiente casi 70 lugares
están contaminados
el paisaje quemado es el mismo que el de
que para there
[Música]
aquí decenas de hectáreas del ecosistema
fueron destruidas
es la fuente de contaminación los
llamamos no pérez
es un equipo de petróleo que llamamos
árbol de navidad
de que se abastece de petróleo la
república federal de nigeria
y del que se abastece este estado y por
supuesto el mundo entero
tras la explosión de una instalación
petrolífera en abril de 2009 decenas de
personas quedaron atrapadas por el fuego
murieron calcinadas
el jefe morgan residente de que paradero
no puede olvidar el horror
vimos desde el pueblo que había una
llama hasta el cielo
debido a que todo este lugar
e incluso el petróleo que se derramó
eran inflamables infame
el fuego alcanzó a nuestras mujeres a
nuestros niños que estaban en su tarea
de buscar probablemente caracoles de
nuestro bosque o cualquier otra cosa o
buscando la unidad de campo hasta la
fecha los habitantes de que paradero no
han recibido ninguna compensación de
health la empresa se niega a reconocer
su responsabilidad según el gigante
petrolero la catástrofe fue causada por
un sabotaje a sus instalaciones la
batalla de las indemnizaciones también
ha dejado víctimas colaterales como es
el caso de esta mujer ciega que perdió a
su marido quien fue condenado a muerte
en 1995 al mismo tiempo que el líder o
gon y quien saro wiva y otros siete
activistas
nuestro hermano ken saro wiwa y mi
marido murieron por causa de los jóvenes
aquellos que están al frente de esta
lucha deberían asegurarse de que el
gobierno nigeriano y la empresa cel
examen en la carta de derechos de los
ogoni que escribió que en y hacer lo que
dice y lo que es más importante deben
respetar al pie de la letra lo que dice
si esto se hace estaremos contentos
porque por fin podremos tener lo que nos
pertenece desde la muerte de quién
saro-wiva todos los que tomaron el
relevo continúa en la lucha contra ser
este es el caso de regalo en su que el
actual rostro de mossos el movimiento
para la supervivencia del pueblo ogoni
regalo en su que apoya a la viuda y agua
ya sus hijos en su batalla legal contra
la multinacional a diferencia de otras
mujeres que fueron indemnizadas tras el
ahorcamiento de sus maridos
blessing agua no recibió ninguna
indemnización
en ese momento self acusada de
complicidad con la junta así que para
evitar una demanda decisiva la empresa
prefirió indemnizar con algo más de un
millón de dólares por familia
de ellos quién saro wiwa y sus ocho
compañeros pedían un trato justo y
equitativo querían una vida normal un
trato justo la junta militar de la época
los mató porque querían continuar
alimentar y mantener una depresión
generalizada entre nosotros los ogoni el
único consuelo que tenemos es que su
muerte no es en vano y hemos continuado
y mantenido la lucha para que su muerte
nunca sea en vano
el hijo mayor de play sin agua sigue los
pasos de su padre
no puedo dejar el mozo
porque por eso murió mi padre y tu padre
construye una casa y se muere tienes que
vivir en esa casa por eso tengo que
seguir a él mosop hasta el final para
conseguir aquello por lo que murió mi
padre
bush haití fund and fue la muerte de su
padre rompió la vida de su familia
tenía menos de 10 años cuando su padre
fue ahorcado con quiénes saro wiwa para
salir adelante
tuca es conductor de mototaxi
caemos en la miseria porque no tenemos
nada una ayuda ningún apoyo financiero
llevó a la gente en mi moto taxi cruzó
mi madre va por las iglesias a pedir
limosna para que podamos comer en 30
años la represión las detenciones y las
divisiones internas han debilitado el
movimiento que defiende los derechos de
los ogoni pero en la línea de conducta
es siempre la misma la no-violencia
debemos enseñarle a la gente que la
no-violencia es una mejor opción que el
camino de la violencia
está claro que nigeria alienta hoy en
día el método de la violencia porque
cuando uno se levanta en armas contra el
estado
es cuando el gobierno llama a la
mediación
y a la compensación
[Música]
el 4 de enero de 1993 en vor y los
fogones le declararon la guerra pacífica
a ser el pescador de bodo el actual
líder de demos y emanuel en qalá estaban
presentes así que nos pusimos en ese
lugar todas las mujeres estaban ahí los
militares estaban ahí y la multitud se
apoderó de este lugar algunos escalaron
este edificio para asegurarse de
participar en la lucha de los ogoni
desde ese día ya no necesitamos a ser en
la tierra ogoni y así sigue siendo hasta
hoy nos declaramos persona non grata y
así sigue siendo hasta hoy
ser sorprendida se vio obligada a
detener sus actividades esto provocó una
gran pérdida financiera para la
dictadura militar en represalia el año
siguiente la represión contra los ogoni
fue feroz durante varios meses célestin
viola su militante muy activo se vio
obligado a esconderse
y yo era un objetivo viviente y vivir en
modo ya no era viable para mí hice mi
escondite aquí solo dios sabe por lo que
uno va a pasar
estaban tratando de asegurarse de
eliminarme junto a otros del moho sopas
los militares violaban a las mujeres nos
torturaban saqueaban nuestras
propiedades y quemaban las casas
y todas aquellas víctimas inocentes no
eran militantes del mosso
y como no lograron encontrar a gente
como yo y trasladaron la agresión a
cualquier persona no les importaba
aunque fuera un niño aquí
como la mayoría de los ogoni la familia
participó en su lucha contra él pero por
otras razones este anciano centenario y
su hijo consideraban que la empresa
estaba pagando mal por el arrendamiento
de sus tierras ganaron su caso contra el
níger
según la sentencia dijeron que él debía
pagar unos 1500 millones de nairas pero
ya saben que mi padre no puede vivir
otros 30 años más
muchos miembros vinculados a este caso
han dejado este mundo y están todos
muertos
[Música]
intentamos reunirnos con un
representante de shell en nigeria
no lo logramos la empresa solo aceptó
responder por escrito
la spd cjb le pagó 380 millones de
dólares al fondo de restauración ogoni
como parte de los 900 millones de
dólares que deben pagarse en un periodo
de 5 años a partir del 2018 fue después
de la publicación de un informe
condenatorio de la onu en 2011 que se le
pagó unos 340 millones de euros a un
fondo encargado de limpiar las tierras o
gon y sin embargo la creación de la
estructura fue ardua y las operaciones
de limpieza comenzaron ocho años después
los ogoni pueden ser impacientes por
falta de comprensión por ignorancia y
pueden ser responsables de esta
impaciencia de extinción y de la falta
de conocimiento largo ahora la gente
también necesita ser educada y que se le
diga exactamente cómo se desarrolla el
proceso se explore al ritmo actual de
construcción y el no cumplirá con su
cronograma de limpieza en voto
esto abre el camino a una nueva demanda
para sus habitantes los habitantes del
pueblo tuvieron que librar una dura
batalla para conseguir que se le
reconociera su responsabilidad en el
desastre medioambiental célestin viola
el pescador de bodo recibió al igual que
los 15 mil habitantes algo menos de
3.600 dólares pero estos subsidios
irrisorios no podrían construir la vida
de sus hijos sin ninguna perspectiva de
futuro
y aquí no hay trabajo para los jóvenes y
los pobres eso hace que los jóvenes
estén desesperados
porque nadie va a luchar por ellos por
eso mi padre tiene esa voluntad de
luchar por ellos
la juventud no ha conocido más que este
paisaje degradado en el que ya no se
puede pescar ni cultivar y es probable
que esto continúe según amnistía
internacional hará falta un siglo para
que hoy uniland ya
vuelva a hacer el santuario que fue
[Música]
hasta aquí esta historia de boletos de
vuelta si quiere verla nuevamente o
conocer más sobre nuestros reportajes no
dude en visitar nuestro sitio web air
france 24 punto com esto es todo por el
momento siga con nosotros
[Música]